all right there's a new movie coming out
called This is what it's called the
American Society of magical
Negroes that's the name of this the book
movie rather uh I want to show you a
clip of this trailer which uh has gone
viral for all the wrong reasons let's
watch
[Music]
it I know you can feel their discomfort
Aaron watching you walk through a room
full of white people was the most
painful thing I've ever seen excuse me
sorry I don't want to take you to a job
interview there's a recruiting class
starting right now and we got to get you
in
it welcome to the American
Society of magical
Negroes I don't really understand it's
easier to
sh what's the most dangerous animal on
the planet sure white people when they
feel uncomfortable white people feeling
uncomfortable precedes a lot of bad
stuff for us that's why we fight white
discomfort every day because the happier
they are the safer we
are um that's real Apparently that is
actually a real thing that they're
making uh have already made I guess and
will be coming out and that's the plot
of the movie basically the premise is
that white people are so volatile and
violent that black people are constantly
having to appease them in order to keep
the peace that's the whole point of the
movie that's some how white people are
dangerous and black people are always
walking on eggshells in order to not
offend not offend or upset them this is
this is the premise of the
film
um
now okay first of all obviously this
movie is absurdly racist obviously
you're not going to see a movie where
black people are called dangerous
animals I mean they put that right in
the
trailer white people are the most
dangerous
animals on the
planet this is not subtle I mean this is
not subtle anti-white racism it's just
this is
fullon
dehumanizing calling them dangerous
animals um and you're not going to see
that in the reverse obviously a whole
plot about how white people have to
civilize black people uh is just not
ever going to exist it's not going to
happen and this movie can only exist
going one way
um it's also just as obvious that the
film will be a flop because who is the
audience for
this like the the audience is going to
have to
be racist black
people and and uh and I guess woke white
people who want to impress racist black
racist black people and the Very woke
white people who want to impress the
racist black people but you probably
can't
even come to think of it you probably
can't even get the second group group
The woke white people they're not going
to come and watch this because because
first of all they're they're not going
to want to say the
title right so like they're not going to
feel comfortable going up to AMC and
going up to the guy the cash register
who who could very well be a black guy
and saying yes I'd like two tickets to
the magical Society of the Society of
magical
uh you know the that one what was that
what did you want it for the Society of
magical uh uh colored people of
color so it's a movie that only W white
people would see but they definitely
won't see it so you're left then with
racist black people as your sole
demographic except that you actually
need racist black people with bad taste
in movies um even more so and I don't
know what percentage of racist black
people have bad taste in movies not
really sure but you you so you've taken
a you've taken one relatively small
demographic and then a a smaller
demographic within that demographic and
then even smaller demographic within the
demographic within the demographic and
it's just probably not going to
translate into a blockbuster
film I don't know what the financial
projections were for this film but
there's no way they looked at the script
and said oh yeah this is a $300 million
movie We're making 300 million on this
thing the holidays are rapidly
approaching but we can find peace and
calm in the craziness of the season with
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the world immerse yourself in
Christmas and Advent prayers meditations
and peaceful Christmas music hallow
offers an ex extensive library of Bible
reading plans accompanied by insightful
Reflections and Audi guided meditations
whether you're a seasoned Bible reader
or just starting your journey H provides
a platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before a great
place to start is with father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year in which he
offers brief daily readings and
Reflections available on the Hallow app
the Hallow app also helps you connect
with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experience insight
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the season with
prayer meditation and Christmas music on
hallow download the app for free at
hall.com Walsh for three months free
that's hall.com
Walsh but of course they're not trying
to make money with this film um they
also aren't trying to tell a good story
or make a quality movie and that's the
odd Dynamic that you see in Hollywood
now see I mean it used to be
that Hollywood would put out some movies
just for the money just for the profit
right the big tent Poole Blockbuster
films and then they' put out other
movies for the artistic credibility uh
films that probably wouldn't make a lot
of money but they' be critically claimed
and people would would like
them and you know and uh and they'd win
some awards and you can build your
reputation that way um and that's the
way that that movie studios used to work
you had movies that were supposed to
make money
and then movies that really weren't
supposed to make money or at least were
not expected to well now you still have
movies that are supposed to make money
and that are only designed to make money
those are the superhero movies and then
you have also have movies that aren't
supposed to make money but the
difference is that the movies that
aren't supposed to make money also are
not made for artistic credibility
anymore now they're made for political
credibility which means that even your
lowbudget
films and and your films that don't make
money are also soulless and cynical just
like the big Blockbusters are so it's
all soulless and cynical all the way
down and uh and this movie clearly
is but the main thing here is just the
is just the the fantasy land
scenario that the left plays in when it
comes to racial issues and and when it
comes to really any issue but especially
on racial issues now obviously the whole
movie is a fantasy movie it it has
magical in the title
but it but it's also obviously supposed
to be saying something about
reality and the thing that it's saying
about reality is just
absolutely
ridiculous like the idea that black
people are walking around all cautiously
around white people because white people
are like are likely to lash out
violently against it's just it's absurd
as if a black person ends up in a you
know is like driving and ends up in a
white suburb and he's lost or something
and he sees that is in a a suburb and
kind of locks the door and rolls the
window up oh no we're in the suburbs now
look at all these white middle-aged
women
jogging I'm nervous I got to get out of
here they just doesn't happen they've
created this Fantasy Land This upside
down opposite Ville
scenario which is always the leftist
strategy um which is not to tell little
lies I mean they tell little lies too
but but it's not so much the little lies
uh they tell really big ones and they
completely deny the most obvious
realities they Rite
reality right in front of our
faces and they and they create this
reality that that that does not
comport with anyone's actual experience
we hear so much about lived
experience okay that's that moveie
that's not anyone's lived
experience um but the this is what they
do and they insist on they rewrite it
and they insist on the rewrite and they
insist that we
all accept the rewrite and and pretend
to believe it and I guess the idea is if
you pretend to believe it for long
enough then you really start to believe
it those white woke white people I was I
mentioned they're not going to go see
this
movie but
um they will Le you know they'll see the
trailer and they'll at least
pretend that the premise make sense to
them they'll say oh yeah yeah that's
right the D white people are the most
dangerous you know black people are
always having to calm us down and stop
us from lashing out like they'll pretend
that they that the premise
resonates and I don't know you pretend
enough eventually do you do you fool
yourself maybe that's the way it works
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there